la france est elle a un bon ou un
mauvais élève en matière d'énergie
éolienne réponse avec frédéric tuiles et
bonjour bonjour alors vous êtes
responsable des études à l'observatoire
des énergies renouvelables est ce que
nous en france on est en retard ou pas
sur le développement notre parc et
d'énergie éolienne terrestre 6 terrestre
à la fois par rapport aux objectifs
qu'on s'est fixés même par rapport à
certains nos voisins qui sont peut-être
plus en pointe que nous alors
effectivement au point de vue du point
de vue des objectifs que l'on s'est
fixés la france est en retard
actuellement nous avons un petit peu
moins de 10 9 gigawatts donc d'éoliennes
de puissance éolienne installée et 30 19
réacteurs nucléaires à peu près c'est ça
voilà en gros peu près voilà et en avant
sur un rythme d'environ 1 gigawatts par
an et le prochain objectif que se fixe
et donc la france c'est à la fin de
l'année 2023 d'atteindre un peu plus de
vingt-quatre gigawatts dont il faudrait
quoi les deux fois plus volé deux fois
plus vite effectivement il y
actuellement environ
2100 parcs éoliens pour dix mille cinq
cents éoliennes sur le territoire bon
qu'est ce qui bloque évidemment le sait
il ya les riverains c'est compliqué déjà
aussi iana qu'on appelle à la lenteur
administrative
ça prend plus de temps france de sortir
une éolienne km oui oui alors
effectivement il donne raison d'imaginer
qu'il ya des raisons parce que
effectivement la france enfin les
développeurs en france mettent souvent
ce point en avant c'est vraiment la
lenteur des services de l'état de
traiter les demandes donc obtenir un le
permis construire et ensuite le
raccordement en france ça prend 6 est
parfois plus sept ans alors que en
allemagne qui est un petit peu le le
père et ference c'est deux fois moins
long
donc c'est vraiment là dessus sur une
fluidification des procédures
administratives que porte surtout et les
desiderata des professionnels mais les
riverains aussi qu'ils n'en veulent pas
globalement je veux dire peut pas lutter
contre les enquêtes dont qui sont faites
dans un cas d'opinion met souvent en
avant le fait que là où il ya des
éoliennes elles sont d'autant plus
acceptée par le citoyen parce qu'ils
voient
köhler leurs craintes leurs leurs
desiderata autour de de l'intégration
d'éoliennes dans leur environnement est
pris en compte et que a contrario il ya
plus de crainte là où on annonce des
éoliennes parce que finalement éclate à
la réalité n'est pas de concertation
c'est ça il alors la concertation en
france il faut tout de même signaler que
les sites éoliens sont soumis à des
contraintes autour du développement du
projet et ensuite donc de leur de la
réalisation des chantiers à des
contraintes assez strictes et sérieuse
tout par exemple tous les sites éoliens
en france sont classées icpe donc
installations classées pour la
protection d'environnement donc au
niveau de l'impact
sur le paysage un pacte vis-à-vis des
riverains
impact sur l'environnement des mesures
sont faites notamment sur le bruit et si
les donc les seuils minimum ne sont pas
respectées à ce moment là le projet ne
se fait pas mais là la contrainte
réglementaire est vraiment sérieux sur
sur l'éolien puisqu'on parle des oiseaux
les lignes électriques font plus de mal
aux oiseaux que les éoliennes c'est ce
qu'a dit d'ailleurs la ligue pour la
protection des oiseaux il ya des idées
reçues qu'on peut avoir sur le sujet
comme alors c'est vrai que on a souvent
parlé de d2 l'impact sur les oiseaux des
éoliennes est justement la ligue pour la
protection des oiseaux donne un ratio
d'environ 6 à 7 oiseaux tués par an par
une éolienne donc l'éolien terrestre
alors bon on peut toujours considérer
bien sûr que c'est cet oiseau de trop
mais il yad'autres disons
actions de l'homme qui sont plus
néfastes comme par exemple
les les pesticides dans l'agriculture ou
le le fait de d'artificialité des terres
qui détruit donc le milieu naturel où
vivent les oiseaux qu'un impact plus
important alors par les éoliennes
terrestres après et aussi les éoliennes
offshore en mer une première éolienne a
vu le jour en france au large de saint
nazaire est-ce que l'avenir des aliens
est plutôt en mer plus que sur terre
l'avenir ici les paiements vers l'avenir
il est aussi en mairie en plus bas c'est
complémentaire c'est à dire que c'est
vrai que le premier étage ils ont deux
éoliennes en france comme en europe
c'était les éoliennes terrestres parce
que c'était plus simple parce que la
technologie était plus adaptée et sans
doute que le prochain étage sera les
halls et nos mères avec dans un premier
temps d'éoliennes donc posée sur le fond
marin c'est donc le cas de ce qui se
passe en ce moment sa nazis après des
fermes éoliennes flottantes voilà c'est
ça ça c'est le coup le coup suivant
quand alors là en fait les premiers en
france au niveau de deux fermes pilotes
et c'est sans doute dans sept huit ans
que vers on verra les premiers projets
vraiment qui injecteront des meilleurs
batteurs sur le réseau électrique dans
l'éolien en mer comme sur l'éolien sur
terre la réglementation a été également
très très stricte et puis il y avait
beaucoup de choses à inventer c'est à
dire qu'au niveau des procédures au
niveau de l'intégration d'éoliennes donc
dans l'écosystème marin haut niveau
effectivement de la cohabitation
d'éoliennes avec les utilisateurs de la
mer oui les pêcheurs il y avait
également aussi
modus vivendi a trouvé et
aujourd'hui la filière avance par
rapport à ces points là mais encore des
questions sont à régler c'est certain
quels sont les avantages des éoliennes
en mer par rapport aux éoliennes
terrestres plus de vent oui donc ça
c'est bien tant qu'il ya moins
intermittence il n'ya pas les nuisances
pour les riverains mais on les a pour
les pêcheurs mettait c'est plus cher à
installer oui oui le coût est plus chère
à l'installation mais du fait que le
gisement éolien est bien meilleur il est
moins perturbé il n'y a pas de deux
bâtiments il n'y a pas de structure pour
le couper en ce moment là on utilise
donc un indicateur qui est le facteur de
charge le facteur de charge s'est en
gros l'estimation du temps sur une année
durant lequel la machine va tourner à
plein régime donc par exemple sur terre
le facteur de charge moyen des éoliennes
en france est d'environ 27% et
aujourd'hui le facteur de charge
observée sur les fermes éoliennes en mer
en europe il est de pratiquement 40%
donc le productible est bien mûre voilà
et donc ce qui fait qu'au final
électricité à base d'éolien en mer
revient moins cher on voulait plus cher
que alors que
c'est à dire que aujourd'hui moins cher
tout à fait moins cher alors aujourd'hui
le coup de l'éducateur éoliens en france
150 jeunes voilà entre 50 70 euros le
mégawattheure et
donc dunkerque qui est un un site d'une
future ferme éolienne offshore en france
donc posé s'est soldée à moins de 40
euros le mégawattheure donc donc c'est
encore plus compétitifs les coûts
d'installation avions plus important est
oui oui oui très compétitif les énergies
renouvelables les plus développés comme
l'éolien le photovoltaïque sont
aujourd'hui à des coûts au niveau du
kilowattheure très compétitif oui je
reviens à l'objectif de la france en
2050 on évoquait en éolien ses 40
gigawatts ça sera quoi fifty-fifty
moitié moitié entre le l'éolien et le
solaire et encore une fois il faut
largement entre l'éolien entre l'éolien
terrestre et l'éolien en mer offshore il
encore il faut accélérer à fond coin oui
il faut accélérer à fond d'autant plus
que au delà des objectifs qui sont fixés
actuellement par un texte qu'on appelle
la ppe la programmation pluriannuelle de
l'énergie c'est un texte national qui
fixe les objectifs pour l'ensemble en
fait deux de l'énergie en france un
panique mende et donc qu'ils énergies
renouvelables l'éolien mais au-delà de
ça par exemple les scénarios qui ont été
sortis par rte en fin d'année dernière
montre que dans tous les cas au niveau
d'électricité française au niveau du mix
électrique france il faudra il faudra
accélérer le développement des énergies
renouvelables y relate rancio nage tout
à fait et respecter les accords de paris
vous remercie beaucoup frédéric tuiles
et donc le responsable études à
l'observatoire des énergies renouvables
merci à vous
[Musique]